In the last lesson, we looked at Motion Problems, by looking at the distance,
rate and times of different objects. We saw how fast some people could bike and
we saw how fast some things could travel. We're going to tackle a similar
Motion Problem, this time it's going to involve a current. And in order to
solve these problems involving current, we want to be clear on 2 words,
upstream and downstream. If we think about swimming laps inside of a pool, I
could say that my speed would be 5 miles per hour. That's about how fast I swim
from each side of the pool. 5 miles per hour would be considered to be my speed
in still water, since there's no current pushing me forward or backward. I'm
just swimming along inside of a pool. But what if instead I went swimming in a
river? A river has a current to it, so if i swim downstream I would be swimming
with the current. And if I swim upstream i would be going again the current. If
the speed of the current is 3 miles per hour. And I know that in still water I
can swim 5 miles per hour, what would be my speed if I was traveling
downstream? And, what would be my speed if I traveled upstream? Write those 2
answers here.